I've been running from King Kong pretty
much all my life we live my friends
pretending to be there or we're chasing
it so an opportunity to be in the film
and actually see myself running away
something that big yeah start to do it
professionally right okay fire it up
that cause you can't I just was so
excited to be in a film about calm I
can't remember when I hold I was when I
saw that first image is here among the
Empire State Building with the lights
planes coming towards them and I just go
Theresa so exciting what my day involves
like running through a boneyard all day
being chased by a giant monster if you
go home with end of the day like I can't
believe that this is my life this is my
job so cool hanging out with the cat
backstage was just a big pleasure and
honor having dinner with John Jackson
and John Goodman and all those
incredible people it was just you know
pleasure application what can audiences
expect to take away from the film
director of course huge you know
excitement big action scenes and more
Kong I think than we've ever seen in any
version of the story
[Music]
you